LAURENT BROSSOIT GETS THE
FOUGHT FOR ALONG THE END BOARDS.
CHANDLER STEPHENSON IS TIED UP
THEROR A PUCK ALONG THE TO FEEL
YOU WON THE POWERBALL.
THEY ARE LOSING
MIRO HEISKANEN TRIED TO FLIP IT
UP THE FOR VEGAS
HAS DONE. LOOSE AND BY.
THE GAME IS
FACED 16 SHOTS IN ONE PERIOD.
THIS THE RIGHT
WING SIDE.AS SECOND LAST YEAR I
THATIT IS A WE
TEAM.
LOW.
IT IS
RADULOV DOES IT EVERY DAY IN
TURNED BACK OVER, A SAVE ON THE
ROY HAD ABOUT LASAS
REDIRECTION.
THE STARS FEELING PRESSURE RIGHT
NOW.
CAN'T GET THE PUCK OUT OA IS HI
AGAIN.
>> Josh: FIVE-ON-FIVE.
BROSSOIT IS IN THE BOARDS.
COMEAU WITH A HIM.
PUT HEISKANEN IN A TOUGH THEIR
BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE URGENCY ON THE
>> Daryl: WHAT HERO IN THE
TIME.
OVER THE LAST BLOCKED.
HINTZ WITH THE FOLLOW UP.
CLOSE.
HAD A HEAD OF STEAM.
>> Josh: KLINGBERG HIT.
TURNOVER VEGAS DOWN